this is aya and sagu - adorable clouded  leopard cubs don't be fooled by the  youthful spirit clouded leopards are  some of the most shy mysterious and  elusive cats besides their shy nature  they have a steadily declining  population making it even harder to spot  them in the wild  as far as big cats go clouded leopards  are the smallest these two little girls  will top out at around 3 feet when fully  grown native throughout Asia they live  in diverse habitats from the rain  forests of Indonesia to the foothills of  the Himalayas they pack a powerful bite  - as they have the largest canine teeth  relative to body size of any wild cat  they have short powerful legs and ankles  that convert eight backwards making them  elite climbers beyond a quickly  shrinking habitat perching remains a  huge problem as their skin claws teeth  burns and meat are all sold on the black  market this is the clouded leopard